[Music]
foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor Hello friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
on May 1st 2023 a plane carrying seven
crashed in the Amazon jungle of Colombia
the soldiers located the wreck and the
bodies of three adults but the four
children ages 1 to 13 were missing
in a coordinated search effort called
Operation HOPE soldiers and Indigenous
people covered approximately sixteen
hundred and fifty miles while looking
for the siblings
incredibly 40 days later after tracking
little Footprints soldiers located the
four children alive
they were very gaunt and dehydrated but
they're expected to make a full recovery
they suffered only minor cuts and
scrapes from the crash
officials especially praised 13-year-old
Leslie for ensuring the survival of her
younger siblings 9 5 and 11 months old
because of their indigenous background
the children had some familiarity with
the rainforest fruits this plus some
cassava flour were the key to their
extraordinary survival in an area where
snakes Jaguars mosquitoes and other
animals abound
because the children lost their mother
the president of Colombia has committed
funds for the care of the children and
to educate them you know Pastor Ross I
think this is just amazing there they
were 40 days and 40 nights in the
wilderness that's right Pastor Doug it's
just it's remarkable for a grown-up to
be able to survive under those
conditions for 40 days let alone three
kids the younger of which she said was
what 14 months the younger 11 months
actually turned one years old during the
40 days that is amazing yeah so they
were Angels unseen that undoubtedly were
protecting them from just the wild
animals and all the things that could
destroy them there so when we hear 40
days in the wilderness well you can
think about the children of Israel where
40 years in the wilderness but you've
got Jesus fasting in the wilderness for
40 days and 40 nights and you can read
in Mark 1 verse 12 and 13.
after his baptism immediately the spirit
of God drove him into the Wilderness and
he was there in the wilderness 40 days
tempted by Satan and was with the wild
beasts and the angels minister to him
I'm pretty sure the Angels took care of
those kids out there that's right and
you get the story where Elijah ran into
the Wilderness and Angels fed him and
then of course Moses was 40 days and 40
nights up on the mountain actually two
times
uh getting the Ten Commandments and
you see a picture then in the New
Testament the three individuals that
fasted 40 days 40 nights in the Bible
are all on the mountain together
Moses Elijah and Jesus in what they call
the Mount of transfiguration and many
people are surprised to know they are
the two witnesses Moses and Elijah is a
symbol of the two witnesses that you
find in Revelation chapter 11.
that's right past it like that is a
great study you just mentioned a few of
the similarities between Moses and
Elijah and Christ what else is
interesting is you have Moses who died
and he was resurrected and taken to
heaven and of course Elijah was taken to
heaven without seeing death it's almost
a miniature of the second coming because
it's going to be those who are
resurrected when Jesus comes again and
there will be those who will be
translated without seeing death so you
almost got a picture here of the second
coming of Christ so much to this story
that we read about we have a book it's
called the two witnesses and it's all
about Moses Elijah Jesus there on the
Mount of transfiguration that is our
free gift for anyone who is listening
all you need to do is uh call the number
800-835-6747 and you can ask for offer
number 195 we'll be happy to send it to
anyone here who is in the US and Canada
if you're outside of the United States
just be sure to visit our website
amazingfacts.org another way that you
can get the free offer is by simply
dialing pound 250 on your smart
smartphone and say Bible answers live
and then ask for the free gift it's
called the two witnesses and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks
we'll pass it out before we get to our
phone lines as we always do we like to
begin the program with the word of
prayer so let's do that now dear father
what a joy it is for us to be able to
open up your word and study together and
Lord we ask for your blessing we
recognize the Bible is your book you
inspire the prophets of old who wrote it
and so we pray for that same Spirit to
come and guide us as we search the
scriptures be with those who are
listening wherever they might be and we
ask this in Jesus name amen amen
I think we're ready to go to our first
caller this evening Pastor Doug we have
got Christy listening in Canada uh
Christy welcome to the program hi pastor
Pastor hi thanks for calling Christy and
your question tonight
uh my question is the ability of
Jeremiah chapter 29 verse 11 and how to
trust in the Lord as David did in Psalms
31 despite the verbal criticisms of
others as a person is I see in the Bible
kind of contrast I guess more literal
since the mind as it's comprised of
school and my grace and my future as
like girl despondent of such matters and
you know worry since I'm not making the
ideal grades even though I try my
hardest and play while reminding myself
of the promises of God
well that's a good question and you know
if if when you pray and you trust God
and you still find yourself struggling
don't be discouraged because there's
many examples in the Bible of people
that prayed several times before they
experienced an answer you can read about
the children of Israel and there was
quite a while that they were crying unto
the Lord for deliverance and says then
the Lord heard their prayer sometimes
during the time of waiting God is
building our faith there's a story in
the Bible about blind bartimias and
Jesus was passing by and he was crying
out and people told them to be quiet but
he kept crying out and then God stopped
and Jesus brought him and healed him you
wonder why did the Lord make him cry out
several times
and there's that Parable Jesus shares in
Luke chapter 18 about the Widow that
continues to go to the judge and say
give me Justice deal with my adversary
and and then finally
the judge says well
she's wearing me down I'm going to
answer and God says how much more will
the Lord answer the prayers of those
that cry unto him day and night so don't
be discouraged Christy you can trust
what it says there in Jeremiah 11 or 29
verse 11. he promises you'll search for
me and you'll find me when you search
for me with all your heart in verse 13
just continue to pursue God and you will
see peace and answers you know Christy
we do have a book for anyone who's
listening and it's about prayer you
mentioned prayer and persistence in
prayer is one of the important
principles that we find in the Bible and
we have a book written called teach us
to pray and we'll be happy to send this
to anyone in the U.S or Canada the
number to call for that is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
book it's called teach us to pray or
just dial pound 250 on your smartphone
as say Bible answers live and then ask
for the book teach us to pray and we'll
be happy to send that to anyone who
calls take advantage of it it's a great
book next caller that we have is Kayla
listening in Tennessee Kayla euron Bible
answers live
caramel yeah just for friends listening
I'll set this up so they have the
background but there's a big Showdown on
Mount Carmel during three and a half
years of severe famine where Elijah
called together all the prophets of Baal
this false god and they prayed and
nothing happened with their altar they
were supposed to pray and fire would
come down but there was no fire but
Elijah said I'm going to pray for fire
to come on God's altar but to prove it's
God
we're going to put three barrels of
water you figure like you know three big
oil barrels of water we're dumped on
this altar to show that it was a
supernatural fire but it's a famine
where's the water coming from well the
famine there was no food there was no
rain nothing was growing there was still
water in the wells and in the springs
not too far away from Mount uh Carmel
you not only have the ocean down the
hill it doesn't say it was fresh water
could have been salt water and you've
also got the gishan spring and uh the
creek there and it probably still had
water in it so they you know and all the
people gathered up there on the mountain
the king probably had bought some
brought some water so that people would
have something to drink up there so
there's a few different options but
Bible says that they had water they just
didn't have any food
all right thank you next holiday we have
is Brittany listening California
Brittany welcome to the program
hey hi
yeah minus if dogs are unclean and
Revelation 22-15 condemns dogs will
therefore attacks be in heaven all right
and says here in Revelation that the
dogs are outside and does that mean
there'll be no dogs in heaven or will
our pets be in heaven you've got a
couple questions there first of all what
is it talking about when it talks about
dogs outside of the New Jerusalem the
word dogs here is not even talking about
people
um you can look where uh Jesus and even
some of the Old Testament people in the
prophecy about Christ when they were
around the cross persecuting Jesus it
says dogs have encompassed me that's
talking about people that kind of rip
and tear into you and so it's an analogy
of evil vicious people
um and even Christ said you don't give
the children's food to the dogs he was
talking about the unbelievers so when it
says dogs are outside the city don't be
thinking of canine or pooches it's
talking about evil people will there be
dogs in heaven God made dogs I'm sure
there'll be dogs in heaven will your
pets be in heaven that's another
question no scripture that guarantees
that God is going to resurrect your pets
there's no scripture that says God can't
do that so
just uh when you get to heaven I'll
promise you you will be happy so don't
be uh don't be discouraged or worried
that's right Pastor like the Bible says
I have not seen nor ear heard neither
entered into the heart of man the things
that God is preparing for those that
love him no one's going to get to heaven
and say oh man I want money something
different it's not quite what I Envision
no it's it's going to be everything that
you can you can't even imagine the
things that God has prepared for those
that love him so we just need to get
there next quality that we have is Glenn
listening in Ohio Glenn welcome to the
program
thank you for
taking all and I'll tell you the amazing
fact it's wonderful not above Yahweh
he's able and he did it again amen you
know
my my question is a little bit strange
I I don't think that God who or God was
very knowledgeable of such a thing as
Sin is evidenced by the scripture that
the Savior slain from before the
foundation of the world but although I
wonder my question is I wonder what was
on his mind when he allowed Satan to
introduce sin to the creation
well I won't pretend that I could read
God's mind uh it tells us that you know
God is past finding out and his ways are
higher than our ways as the heavens are
above the Earth
and I think the nearest star is four
light years away which means if you
travel 186 000 miles a second is it
going to take you four years to get to
the nearest star so God is infinite but
in his wisdom
uh God knew that he would have to take
the risk of making creatures even
powerful creatures like Lucifer that
might choose not to love him because
they're free
and we are all free moral agents and so
Lucifer is exhibit a that God makes us
with a freedom to love him a Lucifer
love God probably for you know Millennia
before he rebelled we don't know he was
one of the highest Angels he was
probably around a long time before the
seeds of Pride and Rebellion grew in his
heart
yes we do have a study guide that talks
about that path I think it's called did
God create a devil and sometimes people
think of the devil they think of Satan
they say well did God create him bad no
that's not what the Bible teaches God
created a beautiful Angelic being the
highest of all the Angels but he created
Lucifer and the other angels with
freedom of choice and he exercised that
choice to rebel against God we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks the study guide is called did
God create a devil and the number to
call is
800-835-6747 and as for that study guide
did God create a devil you can also dial
pound 250 and just say study guide I'll
say Bible answers live and then say
study guide did God create a devil and
we'll make sure that we get that to you
by the way Pastor us we also have a
video online people can watch called
Cosmic conflict you can just go to
YouTube or go to amazing facts and type
in Cosmic conflict I think it's the
first thing that'll come up on YouTube
and it explains how the devil came to be
the devil so you'll enjoy that all right
our next one on the behalf is Dennis
listening in South Carolina Dennis
you're on the air
hey Pastor Doug and uh
Pastor Ross how are you good thank you
for calling
um well my question is
um real quick so I'm on this group on
Facebook and everybody has different
opinions and beliefs
um but it is my understanding that the
Great Tribulation is is a Great
Tribulation for the Believers because
Lily being persecuted by the unbelievers
and it'll be a great um tribulation for
the unbelievers because they are going
to experience
um the wrath of God the uh um the
plagues
well yeah the Bible speaks of this two
great tribulations that Jesus talks
about a historic Great Tribulation that
went from 5 38 to like 1798 during this
tremendous religious persecution
throughout
the Roman Fallen Roman Empire may have
been called papal Rome at that time but
there's a lot of religious persecution
that the church went through it also
talks about a Great Tribulation the Jews
went through so he's also telling the
apostles that Jerusalem was going to
fall they'd go through a Great
Tribulation but there's a final grape
tribulation you read about in Daniel
chapter 12 it says that Michael will
stand up I think this is verse one
Michael will stand up the great Prince
that stands for the children of thy
people and there'll be a time of trouble
such as there never was even unto that
time and at that time many of the those
that sleep in the dust of the earth will
awake so it's saying the Resurrection
comes after this great time of trouble
there's going to be problems not only of
religious persecution not only will
there be plagues I think the the whole
planet is going to be sort of imploding
uh shortly before the Lord's coming so I
think everyone's going to experience
some element of persecution or
tribulation
that's going to come on the whole world
you know Revelation chapter 7 describes
Four Angels holding back the full Winds
of the earth and strife another Angel
comes from Heaven saying don't let go
the winds until we have sealed the
Servants of God and therefore and the
wind represents this time of trouble
this turmoil this conflict and so yes
God is doing a work of sealing but when
that work is finished probation closes
the seven last plays get poured out and
then Jesus comes now the good news is
for the believer when probation closes
God is going to preserve those who trust
in him uh we're reading Psalms 91 no
plague will come nigh thy dwelling on us
and his angels to watch over you but
they there will be those who suffer
before probation closes and some might
even give their life as a testimony of
their faith and it's a witness to others
amen but that occurs before the close of
probation all right thank you Dennis
we've got uh Judith listening in Nevada
Judith welcome to the program
hello
hi uh John and Pastor Doug didn't hear
me yes
yes okay
thanks for taking my call my question is
regarding the um
the lord of the Sabbath who is the lord
of the Sunday Mark 220 Jesus
uh can you please explain in a holistic
way the connection between creation uh
Redemption
and then Recreation
and then restoration to Eternal Paradise
before Adam and Eve sinned and also
please Focus also on uh the mark of the
666b and the Seal of the heavenly father
thank you all right well you gave us a
tall order that Bible prophecy seminar
right yeah all the important prophetic
truths not going to be able to cover all
of that
um now part of what Judith was asking if
you look in for example in Revelation
chapter one I think it's verse 10 John
says I was in the spirit on the Lord's
Day
and some have wondered what is that
Lord's day and I even heard a pastor say
this week that well yeah that was Sunday
well there's no scripture that calls
Sunday the Lord say anywhere in the
Bible
they just that sort of comes from a
tradition if you want to know what is
the Lord's Day the Lord's Day the Bible
says
God is the seventh day is the Sabbath of
the Lord and then you can look in Isaiah
58 he calls the Sabbath my holy day and
Jesus says and she was referring to this
in Mark chapter 2 the son of man is Lord
also of the Sabbath so if there is a day
of the week that God is the Lord of it
would be the Sabbath some have wondered
there in Revelation chapter 1 it says I
was in the spirit on the Lord's day is
it talking about I was in the spirit and
I witnessed the day of the Lord's return
I actually think he had his vision on
the Sabbath day he's just saying that he
was resting that day and God came to him
and spoke to him yeah you know in the
Bible we have the phrase Pastor Doug as
you know we've got the Lord's day and
then we have the day of the Lord right
it's not always the same thing exactly
and then you have the Dead the Lord is
often associated with the second coming
with the establishment of Christ's
Kingdom and power and Glory but the
Lord's day would be the seventh day of
the week correct you know we do have a
book it's one of our study guides and
it's called the last day of history so
if you're wondering what does the Bible
say about the Lord's day you're
wondering about the Sabbath call and ask
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide It's called the last day of
history or dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then again ask for the study guide the
Lost day of History we'll send it out to
you
next holiday we have is Billy listening
in La Billy welcome to the program or I
guess Louisiana
okay
my question is what day of the week
was
Jesus crucified on
well a quick answer would be Friday
and the reason we see this it says the
Sabbath Drew on and they wanted to take
the bodies off of the crosses before the
Sabbath now that Sabbath was also a
Passover Sabbath but it calls it the
preparation day
and then you read in Luke it says that
they went home and kept the Sabbath
according to the Commandment so we know
what Sabbath it was it was the Sabbath
according to the Ten Commandments which
is the seventh day of the week so the
day them immediately precedes the
seventh day which is Saturday and you
know all the Jews today still keep the
seventh day Saturday that would be
Friday that's why many religions call
Friday Good Friday
now some have read in Matthew chapter 12
where Jesus said Moses I'm sorry as uh
Jonah was in the belly of the fish three
days and three nights so the son of man
will be in the heart of the earth three
days and three nights and they think
well in order for that to work he got to
move the day of the crucifixion so were
you wondering about that Billy
yeah
yeah because I've done a lot of studying
on it and everybody believes that he was
close battle Friday
uh preparation day for the regular
Saturday Sabbath but John he quotes in
there that about the half Sabbath
but in other words
you can't get three and a half days from
Friday to early Sunday morning well you
don't mean three and a half you mean
three days
three days right but that is it clearly
says in John that it they left the the
uh Jonah and the whale he'd be in there
in the heart of the earth three
days and three nights that's the only
way I can see the scripture all them
falling in together is if he was
crucified on Wednesday evening
before the uh High Sabbath and entered
into the grave and he'd be in her three
and a half or three days and three
nights which he'd be resurrected uh on
Sunday morning 72 hours later yeah let
me tell you that the place where the
mistake comes in people read that one
verse there you don't want to build a
Doctrine on one verse that one verse
there in Matthew chapter 12 where Jesus
says three days three nights heart of
the earth they assumed the heart of the
earth means only his time in the Tomb
when Jesus is hard of the earth there's
nowhere else in the Bible the tomb is
called the heart of the Earth
when he says heart of the earth he's
talking about in the midst of the world
when Jesus started suffering for the
sins of the world that was Thursday
night the penalty of her sin was not
just death
and it wasn't just the time that he was
in the Tomb it was the suffering and In
The Garden of Gethsemane he told the
disciples now is the hour so that's when
you punch the starting stopwatch you
might say
Thursday night he began the he said not
my will thy will be done the father
uh with Jewish protection for three days
and three nights Jesus was suffering for
the sins of the world and he was beaten
and tried and mistreated and tortured
and uh he rose again Sunday morning so
that's the three days and three nights
it starts Thursday night after the Last
Supper
and so you don't need to move the
crucifixion day because when Luke talks
about the sign of Jonah he never even
mentions in the Gospel of Luke Jesus
talks about the sign of Jonah he says as
Jonah was assigned to the ninevites
doesn't even mention the three days and
three nights so be careful not to try
and move the day of the crucifixion
because of that we do have a free book
we can offer you on that we do the book
is called the sign of Jonah and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
an ass the number is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
The Sign of Jonah we also have a book
called three days and three nights I
think that's two books on the same
subject yeah both are very good uh just
call and ask for either one the sign of
Jonah or three days and three nights you
can dial pound 250 on your smartphone
say Bible answers live and then ask for
the free offer by name and we will send
it to you well let's see pass today
we've got two minutes to go here let's
see if we can maybe get uh Roger in
Minnesota Roger welcome to the program
hi Pastor Doug hi
um my question is kind of heavy it's why
did God choose the number 2300 why not 2
000 or 2400.
are you talking about in Daniel chapter
8 verse 14 I'm assuming
yeah and if you if you would allow me to
respond after your comment I would like
appreciate that okay don't know
hopefully we'll have enough time but uh
I don't I can't give you a reason why
God chose that particular numerical
quantity I just know that God said
that's what the quantity would be from
the starting point to the ending point
of the prophecy
so you must have something in mind
I do okay please because we're going to
run out of time
I'm sorry to hear that
um God gave Moses two festivals to keep
after they left Egypt the Spring
Festival the Fall Festival
and when Jesus was crucified how did he
know he was going to be resurrected on a
third day that's because he was a wave
sheep of the first fruits and how did he
know that was his last supper that's
because on the 14th day of the first
month the Passover Lamb was slain and
Jesus knew he was the Lamb of God so if
the Spring Festival held that much
weight then the fall vessel must hold
also that much weight so if we count the
days God has already given in Leviticus
23 on the first day of the bullying of
the trumpet for 90 days on his 10th day
the day of atonement on the 15th day the
Feast of Tabernacles for seven days and
then there's a eighth they add all that
together and you come up with 22 literal
days
so it first came first Kings chapter 7
and second Kings chapter
seven thereabouts it says that when
Solomon has finished building the Temple
he told the people to go which was and
then he did then they had the feast then
and then at the 22nd day they was told
to go home and First Kings in on the
23rd day they was go told to go home in
Chronicles
so in Daniel 8 says on to 2300 days not
2 300 days and one more is just on two
up to that so you have 22 days 22 and a
half 22 and three quarter 22 and 7 8 22
and 8 8. that brings you right up to 2
300 of 22 full days
and evidently God has taken this 22 full
days
and turned it into
hundreds of days
so is 2300 which is a little over six
years okay well
we're going to run out of time here I
bet you are an accountant because you
got a lot of math going on there hey
friends don't go away we're just taking
a halftime break we're coming back with
the very best A Bible answers live and
there'll be more time to call in your
questions
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
enough amazing
to wait until next week to enjoy more
truth-filled programming visit the
amazing facts media library at
aftv.org at
aftv.org you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
[Music]
life can be overwhelming where can an
on-the-go woman find quality time with
God the new amazing Treasures of Faith
box set from amazing facts empowers your
devotional life with inspiring resources
that will bring lasting peace into your
busy life this beautifully designed box
set by women for women comes with a 31
day devotional recipe and scripture
cards and special messages from Pastor
Doug and Karen Batchelor get your
amazing Treasures of Faith box set today
just call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
millions of people believe that planet
Earth is on the verge of some apocalypse
that will plunge the world's cities into
chaos in response thanking people
everywhere are wondering if it might be
a good time to locate their families
outside of the congested metropolitan
areas in my new book heading for the
hills a beginner's guide to Country
Living I do my best to provide a
Biblical balance I'd like to share with
you some of the crucial things you'll
need to know before you head up for the
Hills
I'd also like to identify some of the
Practical things you look for in buying
a piece of country land how to develop
water power and a garden all while still
seeking to save the lost this book has
some very valuable information for
anybody that's ever considering country
living order your copy of heading for
the Hills call 805
872 Z5 or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you're tuning in and
you've just joined us along the way this
is a live International interactive
Bible study where we take your calls and
recalls from around the world and do our
best to use the Bible resources to
answer any question regarding the word
of God or living the Christian Life my
name is Doug batchler my name is Jean
Ross and friends if you listening on
radio we want to let you know that you
can also participate in this program
live uh by the internet we are live
streaming this program and it's at the
Doug Bachelor Facebook page the amazing
facts Facebook page we're also
broadcasting live on AF TV so uh if you
have a question feel free to give us a
call the number to call for that is
800-463-7297 that's
800-463-7297 and just be patient one of
our assistants will answer the phone and
queue you up and you'll be on the air
next caller that we have is Bob
listening in Washington Bob welcome to
the program
hi thank you very much
um my question is in this time that
we're living now on Earth
is there a connection between physical
healing from God and obedience
yeah well sometimes Jesus healed a
person I'm thinking about the pool of
Bethesda when he healed that man he said
go and sin no more lest a worse thing
had come upon you so there is definitely
a connection between uh sin and healing
not every time some sickness is just
because the you know degeneration of
humanity and disease in the world but
some sickness is brought Upon Us by sin
and and God does still also miraculously
heal
in response to prayer and you know I
think of the verse past today in James
where uh James gives guidance for the
church and he says if somebody is sick
among you let them call for the elders
let them pray over him but there is also
associated with that special anointing
service confession of sin because it
says if he has committed any sins he
shall be forgiven and the Lord will
raise him up so if we are seeking the
Lord to heal us and we know of a sin
that we have not committed or forsaken
or we want to get that taken care of we
want to get that out of the way so that
doesn't become a hindrance to God
answering our prayer yeah it says he
forgives our sins and heals our diseases
and I think it's Psalm 103. so there's
often a connection
thank you hope that helps a little bit
um well all right next caller that we
have is uh Angela listening in Illinois
Angela welcome to the program
hello
um I have a question in regards to acts
23 8.
um it says that for the Sadducees say
there is no Resurrection or Angels or
spirits but the Pharisees believe in all
of these I guess my question is then if
the Sadducees says that that there's no
Resurrection Rangers or Spirits then
what did they actually believe in I mean
seems pretty hopeless doesn't it
yeah I was gonna say there's no hope
yeah the Sadducees were a pretty liberal
group and they thought that you know God
he can bless you in this life if you
obey him but they didn't really talk
about a resurrection or spiritual life
it was all like it's all right here
right now
and um yeah that'd be pretty sad it's
it's almost like those that believe in
evolution that say this is it
so you have yeah you die and you turn
back to fertilizer and that was your
life so I've wondered that before just
uh who would want to be a sadducee
that's why they were sad you see
and they claim to only believe the first
five books written by Moses but in those
first five books you do have references
to Angels yeah so it's kind of strange
how that they they rejected the belief
of angels and the resurrection of course
yeah um you know we have examples in the
first five books of Moses of a
resurrection so you know it is
interesting that yeah that's that's
neglected pushed aside yep all right
next Call of that we have is uh Dale in
Illinois Dale welcome to the program
it's a good evening Pastor Doug Pastor
John
good evening
sir that you believe Sunday worshipers
will be in heaven
and on your amazing facts program on
Hope Channel you said you believe
millions of Sunday worshipers would be
in heaven so my question is wouldn't any
and all Sunday worshipers be disobeying
the Sabbath
well yeah and I did say that and you
know sometimes people have said because
we teach the Sabbath truth on this
program are we saying that all those
people that don't know that truth are
going to be lost and we're saying no
absolutely not it's one of God's
Commandments but there are going to be
people in heaven for example the Bible
says that you're only supposed to have
one wife
but you're going to find people in
heaven like David and Solomon and Jacob
and others that had multiple wives you
read in Acts chapter 17 at the times of
this ignorance God winked at and so
there are people of God who live through
history where maybe they didn't know
certain biblical truths and they lived
up to the light they had and got a wink
at their ignorance but once we know the
truth
for example
uh I don't drink I don't drink alcohol I
think it's a sin I know better I see
what it does
Martin Luther drank
but he lived in a time where everybody
drank beer because the water wasn't good
I expect to see him in heaven he didn't
know
I don't smoke because I think smoke is
smoking is kind of like you know thou
shall not kill yourself it says right
there on the pack this will kill you
well the guy who wrote Amazing Grace
John Newton he smoked they thought it
was good for your lungs back then they
were wrong so there are people through
history that are godly people they just
didn't know certain things and there's
deer Spirit-filled people in many
churches that have not heard what the
Bible says or they've not had it
presented well about the Sabbath truth
still being a Commandment that is to be
kept so do I think there are people that
are going to go to heaven that went to
church on Sunday absolutely
I don't think there's going to be people
in heaven that knew the word of God and
turned away from it the Bible says once
we know what God wants if we turn away
from it that's sin sin is knowing to do
good and not doing it so hopefully that
clarifies that a little bit yeah of
course when everyone does get to heaven
the Bible says that there will be a
gathering that occurs every week it's
not the first day or the sixth day it's
going to be on the seventh it's called
the Sabbath so everyone will be keeping
this sabbath in heaven yeah from one
Sabbath to another All Flesh will come
to worship before the Lord Isaiah 66.
all right thank you next school that we
have is uh Ivan from Mexico
I've been welcome to the program
good evening pastors how you doing doing
great
my question is in uh Second Corinthians
told nine um and he said to me my grace
is sufficient for you for my strength is
made perfect in weakness that for most
gladly I will rather boast in my
infirmities that the power of Christ May
rest upon me
okay
yeah please
yeah Paul had some Affliction he talks
about and he mentions that earlier in
that verse where he said I had a thorn
in the side messenger from Satan no
one's exactly sure what it was but many
speculate he had a problem with his
vision
and he prayed that God would heal him
but God says no you'll notice other
people often write Paul's letters he
dictates for them and there's a few
occasions the Bible where it appears
Paul didn't see what was happening Paul
is basically saying that God is allowing
him to suffer some Affliction that he
would trust the Lord had kept him humble
and he says in verse 7 lest I should be
exalted above measure by the abundance
of Revelations Paul had talked to Jesus
he saw visions and he said you know
God's keeping me humble because I've had
that relationship by this physical
Affliction and I'm going to glory in my
afflictions if that keeps me closer to
the Lord if that's God's will I will
embrace it
and I've I've known people who have
struggled with some kind of physical
handicap and they say God uses to save
me and I thank God for it it's hard to
understand when you're going through it
but in the big picture when we get to
heaven we'll say I I'm glad for the
trials that God sent because he used it
to save me
all right thank you Ivan we got Michael
in Alabama Michael welcome to the
program
oh good evening first uh about a month
ago either Mr Ross or Mr bachelor on
this broadcast answered another caller's
question about the so-called mark of the
beast now I myself am not obsessed with
Bible prophecy unlike countless
thousands of Protestants but of when
your interpretation has frightened me
um it says uh you answered the person's
question either one of you that uh the
beat uh mark of the beast is like the
devil feel of approval in your mind and
heart and spirit a mind and
um your will and your spirit I don't see
that definition
anywhere here in uh Revelation and I
wonder where and how you were right at
this I got obsessed a severe depression
as a baby Christian that teenage
Christian and then obsessive-compulsive
disorder from churchianity from pastors
that taught stuff like this that you
could uh commit
um practically unparnable sins without
knowing it because uh you have some
secret almost like you have some secret
Covenant with Satan just for being here
or something well let us get it jump in
here and try and say something uh to
respond
so I again I don't know exactly what
question or which one of us responded to
it we probably pretty much believe the
same thing on this because it's it's not
new with us the the teaching through
history and it's from the Bible is that
the mark of the beast is really the
opposite of the Seal of God talks about
the mark being in the hand or in the
forehead if you look in the Old
Testament Moses after giving the Ten
Commandments says in Deuteronomy chapter
6 these words I command you this day
shall be in your heart you shall bind
them for a sign upon your hand they
shall be as frontless between your eyes
that's talking about the forehead
biblically the law of God was to be in
their hand and again you read in Isaiah
chapter 8 it says that we are sealed
with the law of God so the law of God is
sealed in our hearts and our minds if we
do not have the law of God we'll have
the laws of the beast in our minds and
um
ultimately it's going to mean they're
obeying the laws of the Beast instead of
the laws of God you look in Daniel
chapter three and it's got the king
making everyone worship a image or he
would be killed Revelation 13 is
hearkening back to that it says those
that do not worship the image of the
Beast would be killed if we obey the
laws of this final beast power that'll
be in conflict with the law of God
um we're going to have the Seal of God
but we'll be persecuted by the Beast as
a death penalty now I'm not saying this
to scare you I just have to tell you
what the Bible says it's pretty clear
it's happened several times in history
you know past like I think not only does
the bible portray it but we can just
look in the world around us we're in the
midst of a great controversy between
good and evil there are all bad things
happening to good people there are bad
things happening to bad people there are
Wars and there's unjust things happening
all around us and the question is why
well the Bible gives the answer it says
that Satan is the author of pain and
suffering and death and God wants to
save us and that's the whole Plan of
Redemption why Jesus came but Bible
prophecy points to this final showdown
that occurs just before Jesus comes and
you're going to have two groups in the
world those who love the Lord keep his
Commandments and have the Seal of God
and those who follow man-made tradition
they have rejected the Commandments of
God they end up with the mark of the
beast so two distinct groups just before
Jesus comes now Michael I detected in
your question that you you are feeling
some anxiety
and God wants to give you peace and I
think if you study the subject I think
you'll see that uh The Book of
Revelation has a happy ending for those
that Embrace Jesus and uh you shouldn't
be frightened by this when you you know
accept the Lord we're going to send you
a study on the mark of the beast and it
ends with good news and all you have to
do is call the number please look at the
study and it gives you all the
scriptures on the subject matter of fact
you might want to ask for the whole
series that's just one study one lesson
amongst many but you'll be blessed if
you go through the whole set it's all
free just ask for the amazing facts
Bible School the number to call for that
is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
on the mark of the beast but I'd
encourage you ask for all of the studies
and I'll be happy to send it to you dial
pound 250 if you have a smartphone and
you can just say Bible answers live and
ask for the amazing facts Study Guide
Series and we'll get that in the mail
thanks for your call we've got Sue
listening in New York Sue welcome to the
program
hi thank you good night pastas I would
just like you to explain Mark 2 27 which
says the Sabbath was made a man and that
man for the Sabbath please thank you
yeah well we'll read also verse 28
therefore the son of man is Lord also of
the Sabbath
um this verse Jesus you always want the
context
the religious leaders were giving the
apostles a hard time because they were
going through the fields as they walked
with Jesus they're grabbing some of the
heads of grain they'd rub them in their
hands it was Harvest Time and they'd
blow away the chaff they'd pop up in
their mouth I see corn out of a field of
green sometimes and and um
and they're the the religious leaders
that were watching this said oh they're
harvesting well they weren't harvesting
it's like picking an apple on the
Sabbath day is not harvesting but they
were very legalistic and they said
you're harvesting and Jesus said no
they're just they're gleaning a little
food to eat and they were putting all
these man-made laws on the Sabbath like
the reason that man existed was to serve
the Sabbath and Jesus reminded them that
man was made first and the Sabbath was
made to be a blessing for man because
man was made on the sixth day the
Sabbath and was made this period of time
to be a blessing for man in his
communion with God that's why he said
the Sabbath was made for man and not man
for the Sabbath so we shouldn't be
legalistic about Sabbath keeping as the
Pharisees were but neither should we
neglected Jesus never said ignore the
Sabbath that's done away with he said
the son of man is Lord of the Sabbath
meaning and I'm the one that created the
Sabbath and Jesus all things that were
made were made by him he made it to be a
blessing not a burden and that's simply
what he's teaching there all right thank
you sue next holiday we have is Tim
listening in Texas Tim welcome to the
program
hey how you doing doing great thank you
and your calm oh my question yeah my
question is uh
in heaven talks about the tree will be
um the leaves will be for the healing of
the Nations why would there be healing
of the Nations if it's a perfect world
yeah that's that is a good question
um you can also look in
um the end of Ezekiel Pastor Ross might
find the verse where he says you type in
the word medicine you'll probably find
it it says the leaves of the tree will
be for medicine and it's a similar
Vision that Ezekiel has a lot of
comparisons between Ezekiel and
Revelation in this respect
um
obviously nobody's going to get sick in
heaven and need to go you know climb or
crawling up to the the tree of life and
rubbing the leaves in a wound or
something like that the way that I've
understood it is there's two things you
notice it says healing of the Nations it
doesn't say healing of disease
all the nations are divided in this
world by language and culture and
politics and different things as God's
redeemed gather together under the tree
under the leaves of that tree to eat the
fruit all the divisions of the nation
will be healed and we will be one people
so it's a healing of the Nations
um and when we're resurrected though
we'll have glorified bodies man has been
stunted by sin and again not only will
we be eating the fruit it's possible
that maybe there'll be some edible
properties of the leaves and they'll eat
that and grow up to the full statue
because it does say in Malachi they
shall go forth and grow up as cast of
the stall so we may even increase in
height and so can't wait to get to
heaven find out but yeah the verse that
it's um that's drawn from in Revelation
is Ezekiel chapter 47 verse 12. yeah
okay it's about the leaves of the trees
used for medicine all right good
question Tim next quality that we have
is Joel in Tennessee Joel welcome to
Bible answers live
thank you for taking my call my question
regards to Matthew 5 verse 19.
okay I can read it if you want
yes please
whoever whoever therefore breaks one of
the least of these Commandments and
teaches men so he'll be called least in
the Kingdom of Heaven but whoever does
and teaches them he will be called great
in the Kingdom of Heaven
so are you wondering what that verse
means
I was wondering are there levels in like
are there levels or like positions that
people have when they get to heaven yes
but that is not taught by this verse
when I say will there be levels it's not
that God segregates Us in heaven but
Jesus tells us there are varying degrees
of reward
both for the saved and the lost you know
Christ says that those that knew their
masters will and did not do it are
beaten with many stripes while those who
did not know their masters well but
somehow disobeyed or beaten with few
stripes and the Bible also says great is
your reward in heaven those who are
persecuted for righteousness sake so
there's varying degrees of reward but
this verse when it says if you're
teaching others to break the Commandment
you'll be called least in the Kingdom
that's not saying you're in the kingdom
and you're going to be a low position it
means the people in the kingdom of God
call that individual the lowest kind of
person
the people that teach others to sin not
going to be in the Kingdom he's simply
saying whoever breaks the least of these
Commandments and teaches men so shall be
called least those in the kingdom of
heaven will call that person the lowest
kind of person so they're not going to
be in heaven if anyone's teaching people
to sin
I do have another question it's about
like pastors that that may not be
um all-knowing of the truth or like if
they teach like uh if they're ignorant
of something and they teach others to
sin kind of would they still be in like
I don't know if that kind of ties in oh
well yeah you know when the apostles
first when they fought Apostles first
started teaching under Jesus they didn't
have all of their eschatology correct
even after the resurrection they said
Lord will you at this time establish the
kingdom and then even after Jesus
ascended to heaven
they didn't think they were supposed to
preach to the Gentiles and so their
knowledge grew uh with time so you know
I've I've preached before and did
evangelism LED people to the Lord but
then later I realized you know I said
something that actually wasn't accurate
and I of course correct that and I grow
in my knowledge so I I think if a pastor
makes a mistake an honest mistake in his
teaching because he really believes
something that he's just misinformed you
know God is going to wink at that
ignorance and he'll bless the ministry
as much as he can I think there there
are Godly ministers in many churches
that are doing their best to lead people
to Christ and repentance and Faith they
may not have all their theology Square
as I'm sure mine isn't perfect but um
what Jesus is saying here in Matthew
Chapter 5 19 is different this is people
teaching people to disregard God's
Commandments
all right thank you for your call Joel
we've got Matthew listening in Arizona
Matthew welcome to the program how's it
going pastor's uh blessings thank you
um the question is did Noah preach to
the whole world being that the whole
world was flooded
yeah but keep in mind that
um in the time of Noah while there may
have been hundreds of thousands or even
millions of people that lived in the
world I think they were mostly uh
restricted to one section of the planet
they had not dispersed all over the
planet and so you know we ever know I
had the ark parked where he was
preaching probably not too far from the
gates of the Garden of Eden that um he
was preaching to the people he may have
gone on a circuit preaching during the
120 years he was building the ark I
don't know that he was a global jet
Setter back then and that there were
people all over the planet
so
um I don't know you got any thoughts on
that yeah but I don't think it was just
Noah that was preaching there were
others probably passed away
and others yes they live for hundreds of
years so a wood got around people would
speak so even if it wasn't Noah speaking
there were others that testified saying
judgment is coming yeah maybe they had
the internet back then maybe that's up
for communications yeah all right well
thank you Matthew the next caller that
we have is Israel in California Israel
welcome to the program
hi uh thank you and thank you for your
ministry it's meant a lot to me thank
you my question is uh concerning
transgender theory is there any way that
it correlates with the Bible is there
any way that transgender and queer
theory of some denominations have
accepted it
um what are your thoughts on this as far
as it relates to the scriptures
yeah well I'll do my best I guess I'm
pretty simplistic about it in that the
Bible says that in the beginning God
made them male and female not only is
that in Genesis Jesus quotes it that
leaves two options when it comes to
gender you're male or female and in
every human body every female is stamped
with a double X chromosome while every
male is stamped with an X Y chromosome
so
um even if a person goes and has some
kind of reconstructive surgery
their their maleness or femaleness is
stamped on the chromosomes and that's
not changed by that God wants us to
celebrate the distinctions about being
male or being female now I you know my
heart goes out to people that struggle
with very strong feelings towards sin
uh whatever those feelings might be
where everyone struggles with sin and
some people struggle with how they feel
about being a boy or a girl and while I
don't understand it my heart's go out my
heart goes out to them but I know that
we all need to bring our feelings in
harmony with the word of God and ask for
God to uh transform us it's called
conversion the world doesn't believe in
conversion Theory but God does and we
can be new creatures
the Bible is pretty clear uh Deuteronomy
chapter 22 verse 5 the Lord says a man
shall not put on the Garment of a woman
nor shall a woman put on a man's garment
all that do so are an Abomination to the
Lord the Lord wants us to not only
celebrate but to preserve the
distinction between men and women
and in the last days the devil is
attacking every institution that God
established in the Garden of Eden the
devil is attacking well we've talked
about the Sabbath night he's attacking
that day of rest and people are working
themselves to death the devil is
attacking family and the devil's even
attacking just the distinction in the
genders so everything you see
established in the Garden of Eden is
sort of under attack right now and that
would be part of it hey for our friends
listening we're going to sign off in two
stages God bless to those listening on
satellite stay tuned the rest of you
coming back in just a moment with rapid
fire Bible questions stick with us
foreign
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
Hello friends welcome back and as you
can see we can't take the radio programs
but with those of you who stayed around
on aftv you're watching on the internet
we have just two minutes to answer the
email questions that have been sent in
if you have an email question just
simply send it to BL questions at
amazingfacts.org all right Pastor Doug
first caller that we have or first
question that's been emailed to us I
should say which are the member of the
trinity
spoke to the prophets for example Moses
or Isaiah well when you say which member
of the Trinity father son the Holy
Spirit the father typically communicates
to us through the son and through the
spirit there are a few times where you
had what they call a christophany where
it seems that Jesus may have been the
one that actually wrestled with Jacob
and Jesus who spoke to Moses and Jesus
who met with Abraham so there are
examples of Christ himself coming to
Earth and speaking most of the time God
spoke through the Holy Spirit and I
think it says that through the spirit
God spoke to the prophets
spoke as they were moved by the holy
spirit so in in most cases it would be
the function of the third person of the
godhead the Holy Spirit to communicate
the will and the mind of God to the
prophets and the Patriarchs and the
Kings all right very good uh Pastor
here's the question Galatians 2 18 is
the verse and the person is asking about
what law is being referred to here in
Galatians chapter 2 verse 18. all right
and I think we need to read more than
just verse 18. it says in verse 17 but
if while we seek to be justified by
Christ we ourselves are also found
Sinners is Christ therefore a minister
of sin certainly not for if I build
again the things that I destroyed I make
myself a transgressor that's verse 18.
for I through the law died to the law
that I might get might live unto God
well of course according to the law
we're all guilty of sin we are condemned
through the law the penalty for sin is
death but when we come to Christ we die
to self that's what Paul is talking
about we take up our cross and we follow
Jesus and we're dead to law and we're
dead to the pin that doesn't mean we
don't disobey the law but we're dead to
the penalty of the law through the
sacrifice of Jesus now we live lives of
obedience through the power of Christ
okay we're not doing it because it's the
law but because we love the Lord amen
all right last question how do you
respond to someone if they keep telling
you that well that's just your
understanding of the verse well Peter
warns against those who have a private
interpretation we shouldn't all be
coming to our own feelings about it uh
we need to compare scripture with
scripture and I believe when you do that
that's how you find evidence to arrive
at truth we want to thank you for tuning
in to Bible answers live and we'll study
again next week
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]